hello everyone and welcome to some fun
games from the anxious rapid Division 1
verse winner section uh we're gonna show
both games as they both just finished
and they are fairly short first one is
Fabiano caruana with the white pieces
where he plays pretty much like tal he
tries going all out against Magnus so we
will very much enjoy what happens and
second one even shorter another versus
Levon aronian who also play a really
really complicated game but only 21
moves uh and uh well you you'll see what
I mean by this that's why I'm putting
two games in one video so let's check it
out Fabi has the white pieces this is
the semi-finals of the MGs rapid let's
check it out Fabi opens with Ponte E4
and of course by now you all know what
Magnus replies the E4 we we have Pawn to
C5 the Sicilian Defense Knight F3 E6 and
pawn to D4 Fabi not afraid of an open
fight with sea characters Knight
captures and Knight the C6 with Knight
the C3 and queen to C7 the bastric or
variation of the Timon of Sicilian
Bishop to E3 and now Ponte A6 all been
played before nothing new Here pawn to
G4 by Fabi Ponte H6 and Ponte H4 and
here you will uh there are some games
for Knight to FS this was played also
nice the E5 is a known move but Magnus
plays Pawn to B5 and it is now as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game so let's see how Fabi deals with
this he first trades Knights on C6 we
have captors captures and now Queen to
B2 developing the queen preparing
castles Queen side uh and then something
like maybe uh Queen to B2 but we have
Pawn to B4 Magnus says but what about
your E4 pawn and Fabi says you are
welcome to uh Feast yourself on that
pawn and okay night day two and Magnus
says all right I will have some of that
action and I'm attacking your Rook so
you still can't uh Castle uh Queen side
so Rook the G1 also defends the G4 pawn
and now Queen back to C4 now okay you
might run into some discoveries but
there just aren't any good discoveries
here and also if the Knight moves Magnus
will just move the queen back to C7
which is a pretty natural Square in this
line so Knight to a form attacks the
queen just Queen back to C7 and Fabi
Castle's Queen side so you can see that
Magnus only has a queen out whereas Fabi
has a developed Rook Queen uh Bishop
Knight
uh all that for the price of one pound
so can he make something out of that
well Magnus continues development Knight
to F6 and now Bishop to G2 with Tempo
but Magnus also develops uh by
countering that Bishop to B7 Bishop
captures Queen captures and now even
Pawn to F3 Fabio offers another Pawn uh
but this one is not as
um uh well it it it it's definitely a
tasty Pawn but you can't really capture
it if you play a queen captures on F3
then Pawn to G5 and already you're
playing some sort of a weird attacking
game captures captures Knights to D5 and
now Rook GTA E1 and um well how are you
getting that blacking anywhere G6 is
coming you can't even trade here because
of Queen captures on B7 Checkmate so
maybe grabbing that F3 Pawn is not worth
it so after F3 Magnus just plays Rook to
C8 and now we have Pawn to G5 Fabi
continues his attack captures captures
and now Knights the G8 but okay uh G6
will come at some point but also Magnus
now has a fully open H file for his Rook
which he can use to get the Rook into
the attack uh if if possible we have
Bishop to D4
now putting pressure on G7 so the bishop
cannot move and queen to C6 now the
White Queen cannot move as the C2 Pawn
is threatened this would be Checkmate if
the queen moves so King to B1 and now
Rook the H4 putting pressure on that
Knight and of course we just said that
the White Queen cannot move so real
captures an F4 wins the game as Queen
cannot capture due to Queen captures
here so Pawn to B3 now Fabi anticipates
this and he invites The Rook captures on
F4 but now it's not as potent because
now I have to Rook captures and queen
captures uh Queen captures and C2
doesn't really do all that much King to
A1 and with this diagonal open uh open
uh the bishop is doing a fine job at
defending so instead after B3 Knight to
E7 now Magnus brings the Knight into the
game also by playing B3 5 is someone
weakened the C3 Square so the Knight
might come to C3 if you allow it also
the Knight might come to F5 to put
pressure on the bishop so here we have
Bishop back to B2 and Magnus goes Knight
to F5 we have 9 to the D3 now putting
pressure on the B4 Pawn but not really
you can't really do anything about that
again if captures captures the queen
cannot capture because the C2 Pawn will
be weak so we have Bishop to D6 and now
Knight to E5 offering a trade here
attacking the queen and even though it
seems like the bishop is very strong
here the Knight is stronger so it's a
good trade Bishop captures we have
Bishop captures and now Pawn to B6
Magnus just chases away the bishop
Bishop to beat you and only now Magnus
grabs the pawn queen captures an F3 he
says alright you give me one Pawn now
you're giving me the second Pawn uh
where is the counter play I'm up two
points am I just completely winning here
uh well let's see Ponto G6 Fabi
continues the attack we have Pawn to F6
and now Rook G to E1
uh putting pressure on the E6 Pawn but
Magnus is just a very nicely placed King
to D7 defending both D6 and E6 pawns and
now the problem is if you go Rook to F1
with some idea of capturing and uh here
so you can threaten the D6 Pawn is the
Knight is covering that Queen can go
back to C6 and just defend that pawn
it's not really a problem so rookie two
here and now we have Rook to E4 offering
a trade of Rooks we have Rook to H2 5 is
still hoping uh to get a rook lift in
and now Pawn to D5 we have Pawn to A3
trying to get that pawn off of B4
characters and now Bishop to A1 but now
Magnus is completely winning we have
Knights to E3 attacking The Rook here
and just Rook to C1 and here uh the
position is completely winning for
Magnus feel free to pause the video and
win the game in a in a uh uh you know
classy way while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not going for
the boring Knight to F1 fork and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is night captures on C2 this is
what Magnus played and here Fabi already
realized what is going on uh there is
not much you can do hero captures on C2
was played Queen captures on B3 with
check and now the problem is uh you
can't go anywhere even if you try to
give up a piece look at this Rook
captures on C2 Queen captures and now
Rook D1 with check the bishop cannot
block so you have to block with the
queen and now even A1 a to check King A1
Road captures with check Bishop captures
and queen to B1 will be Checkmate so
after this queen characters on B3 check
we have King to C1 but it doesn't help
just real captures and see to check and
it was in this position on move 36 that
Fabiano Corona resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is if you trade Queen
captures on C2 then it's just a
Checkmate Rook to E1 checking the D2 and
queen to E3 is checkmate
and if you don't capture if you play
King to D1 not much better just Queen to
B1 check only move Queen to C1 and queen
characters and C1 will be Checkmate so
very nicely done by Magnus with the
black pieces we'll see Fabi is able to
bounce back and yeah for those of you
who are into that kind of thing Magnus
did win this game with a 98.2 percent
accuracy which is quite a lot uh and it
you know it means that the strongest
engine that they are currently using uh
to analyze um uh the games that are
being played uh agrees with Magnus at a
98.2 percent uh so yeah very nicely done
by Magnus and like I said we're also
going to check out the other game
between another back and another back
and Levon so let's check that out
another back had the white pieces and
it's like super super quick game uh
because uh we have 13 moves of theory
and then as soon as we get out of theory
it's game over so E4 was played with
Ponte 592 F3 Knight to C6 and now Knight
to C3 going for the three nine and
Knight to F6 going for the Four Knights
game Bishop to C4 and now Knight
captures on e4 of course idea being that
if Knight captures D5 can be played but
another way continues in the style of
morphy he continues um with the
sacrifice Pawn castles Knight captures
on C3 now D captures in C3 again this is
how morphe played it back in the day H6
and now Queen to D5 putting pressure on
F7 threatening Checkmate so Queen to F6
and now Rook to E1 preparing characters
on E5 so D6 and now bishopter B5 just
preparing Bishop captures on C6 Bishop
to D7 and now Knight to D4 or made
possible by the Rogue being an E1 and
here just Knights the d8 Levon offers
trades and he's very happy with his
position we have Pawn to F4 uh just
trying to open up the center to attack
the black king and now C6 attacking the
bishop the queen and here you think okay
maybe maybe another wreck went a bit too
far with this I mean what is he doing
he's just uh he's just playing you know
coffee chess uh this is how you'd play
you know in a bar but this can actually
be played because here we have F
characters on E5 attacking uh levon's
Queen and queen back to E7 he says all
right but again your queen and Bishop
are hanging uh and here another Wick
Place Pawn to E6 and just look at this
amazing position what is it what is what
is this what what is happening here the
pawn can be captured by the pawn by the
bishop by the Queen by the Knight okay
obviously not by the queen but it's the
D6 square is definitely attacked four
times the bishop can be captured the
queen can be captured like what what is
happening here well uh can you just
trade Queens here no no you most
certainly cannot because if a phone
captures Queen then Pawn captures Bishop
with Checkmate uh yes it's check and the
queen cannot move to the rook and E1 uh
this would be devastating so uh another
thing you could play is Bishop captures
but then you get something like Knight
captures on C6 and now a very very
complicated position where you actually
have to capture with the Knight because
if you trade Queens here then Knight
captures an E7 comes with a discovery
and once you block this uh sorry once
you block this then Knight captures and
D5 comes with a second Discovery and
black just resigns here so a very tricky
position uh here after this Pawn D6 move
lever one actually capture with the
Knight which is perfectly fine even
better for black and now we have Bishop
captures on C6 another big sacrifices a
piece uh B captures Knight captures now
attacking the queen and of course you
cannot capture with the bishop uh
because just Queen captures with check
and then the Rook hangs uh so Queen to
H4 and now Rook to E4 okay The Rook is
attacked now that we just counters by
attacking lavon's Queen he goes back
Queen to F6 and now Bishop to E3 look at
this incredible development by another
Beck uh and you can still play it but
you have to play Rook to see it you
cannot allow this tension to continue
building up but Levon thought he was
perfectly fine he played Bishop D7 he
probably even felt really good about it
because if Knight captures on E7 he can
play King captures and then the Rooks
are connected and his King will be very
safe on E7 but he forgot the one very
important thing and that is Knight
captures on E7 but not right away first
Rook to F1 attacking the queen we have
Queen to G6 and now Knight captures on
E7 King characters yes the Rooks are
connected and now Rook to D1 and here
well it's a very very difficult position
for Levon and he is a lower on time he
has some seven minutes another way has
12 minutes on the clock and he thought
okay the D6 Pawn is hanging I'm just
gonna give back some material I'm just
gonna play King to f8 and then hide my
king and G8 and then H7 but he
completely missed that his rook and 8
was saying this is another big plate and
of course Levon resigned as he blundered
a full Rook so that's why it was so
short only uh 21 moves uh I mean what
are you gonna do and it's not okay it's
not that telephone just blundered
Rockets because I mean look at this uh
you look at this ugly position Ponte E6
he he probably just used up all his
brain power uh for this one game after
another back executed this Pawn to E6
move because what what do you do when
you face such a move with Black here I
mean it's it's so disgusting we can even
look at it from Black's perspective look
at this I mean imagine if someone you're
playing and someone plays this I mean
what do you play you just uh you know
walk up and leave the room you don't
play this uh so of course you know uh it
had a you know uh dire repercussions uh
so yeah and that's the game or rather
those were the games hope you guys
enjoyed that where if you have any other
games that you are enjoying from the
anxious Rapid or anywhere else do use
hashtag suggestion and I will definitely
go over them I would like to thank James
Eugene Cashman uh Paul Miller Brad Roth
Michael Marshall and bullet just
thriller.com for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up any wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day